from total newbies to seasoned voice
actors to world famous musicians this
cast brings all the talent and skill we
could ever want how dare you take
advantage of her we are taking a look at
16 of the actors behind the voices of
the characters in turning red and how
their experience with this film was
let's go
number one
make way for may
i can't believe that they casted me for
this she might not be able to but she
better believe it because newcomer
rosalie made her mark with her portrayal
of may which for the actress herself was
a total dream come true i have been
watching pixar my entire life in the
booth her creativity in spunk knew no
bounds oh my gosh that was the best
thing ever r
you
serious what's even more impressive is
the fact that the actress managed to
build such a strong bond between her
character and her mother played by
sandra oh without even being in the room
together we both recorded separately i
had no idea how the other house sandra
would say her line and vice versa the
actress kind of came of age herself
while portraying a young woman coming of
age i started this when i was 12 and i
ended on my 16th birthday we've got a
feeling this firecracker is just getting
started she also happens to have a
budding career as a poetry writer
number two from grey's anatomy to
killing eve to turning red i play the
character of ming who is mae's mom has
there ever been a role we haven't loved
the sandra owen the actress has never
experienced a filming process like this
though the last part of all the dialogue
was during the lockdown and during the
pandemic so what happened are you hurt
are you hungry um rosalie and i both
recorded at our separately it at our own
homes working with the director on a
screen and no co-star is tricky but oh
didn't fail to bring all that energy i
knew you were trouble i have a
double-jointed elbow look i can make a
perfect circle for the actress this part
was particularly fun because of just how
creative she got to be with her choices
as ming going from the regular version
of herself to the younger version of
herself to the giant panda version
there's a there's a wide range in vocal
range
number three
from netflix series regular to featured
pixar movie performer so yeah it's
really really cool yeah no kidding i'm
maitreyi ramakrishnan and i play priya
the actress is most well known for
playing devi in the series never have i
ever and at just 20 years old she's
established a pretty incredible career
for herself the fact that she's canadian
made this project that much more
exciting but really it was a dream come
true in every way and she just
appreciated every minute of it i got you
girl
number four
need an energetic voice ava's got you
covered hi guys i'm ava morse and i'm
the voice of miriam she's a literal
teenager but that doesn't mean she isn't
a pro morse actually voiced the
character of ava and ron's gone wrong
playing nerium is definitely not a bad
second voice role miriam is just an
accelerated version of me in case there
were any doubts a buzzfeed quiz has in
fact confirmed that this actress was
made for the role i did get my character
out i feel like perfect casting buzzfeed
confirmed
number five she's made a leap from tech
to talent i'm hayne park i play ebby
this might be her first acting role ever
but she's no stranger to pixar park has
been a storyboard artist on some stellar
pixar projects including soul toy story
4 and bow i feel very proud to say the
least getting into character essentially
took operating at the fullest capacity
possible park knew what was expected so
my character is this crazy ball of
energy that gets super intense like
thousand percent luckily portraying the
wild abby was a pretty simple task for
her that was pretty much me as a
teenager
angry ball of energy number six
she's no stranger to the booth for
voicing a character that was so weird
for me i loved it though yeah that's
another story my actual legs are shaking
so much uk singer songwriter sensation
anne-marie is at home in a booth but the
thought of just speaking was a little
bit of a foreign concept to her i was
pretty shocked about it i was shocked
that people would want my voice
like it i love it i'll give you anything
my talking voice
involved in something while she managed
it well it was much tougher than the
performer anticipated i thought that
this was it was going to be easy i was
like easy but in the booth the
possibilities are endless there's just
so many ways to say something by the end
of the process anne marie had developed
a whole new appreciation for voice over
acting and for director domishi who did
all of her directing from a tablet
hopefully that's recognize my voice
number seven
aunt helen is here and she's anything
but quiet i'm on the red carpet because
my voice is in the movie what meet
sherry cola actress and comedian
extraordinaire with credits ranging from
multiple series regular roles and even
voicing a video game character as for
doing turning red well this casting was
a reason to celebrate and she got a
bonus workout and while she rocked it in
the booth honestly voicing an animated
character so fun because you really use
more than the voice like i'm sweating in
there
number eight he writes he sings now he
acts no one can deny the fact that
phineas o'connell has talent seeping out
of his pores but he was just as excited
about the fact that he got to be part of
this movie as the production team was
when he signed the gig when we got
approached about this project we left at
the opportunity he was pulling double
duty creating those sweet four town
melodies and belting them out in the
booth as jessie
number nine
say hello to one of the coolest
vietnamese-american base vocalists
around
playing guarantee
well let's just say he was a little bit
excited about it so being part of a boy
band is like dream come true i've always
wanted this since i was a little kid the
process was strange from listening to
demo tracks and learning it all alone to
being in the studio under very different
circumstances while they were separated
by literal walls the power of music
still managed to bring them together so
we found a group blend and a group sound
and group groove you know what i mean
all together topher was all about that
base in the soundtrack a definite perk
in his eyes
number 10 any guesses which boy band
member he plays i play tae young he's
known as the cute one in the boy band
that's right seems like appropriate
casting this recording process was far
from typical the performer's only
getting to blend their sound on the
actual recording day
being physically separated made it tough
to collab but that didn't mean the band
wasn't able to work their magic together
anyway we could like see each other but
we couldn't like really interact with
each other other than just like looking
at each other and like kind of vibing
off of each other's energy grayson is a
jack of all trades and brought more than
just his vocal skills to the table
another thing that my character does is
he's also a beatboxer
number 11 hollywood and broadway star
here no big deal
when they offer to be part of turning
red came to fisher it was a pretty easy
decision the collaborative efforts with
phineas and billy that that that caught
my eye
quickly
i think when it was when it was brought
to me the actor has his pick of projects
but the last time he lent his voice to
an animated disney movie it was for the
moana soundtrack
number 12
aaron z is on the mic i'm the biggest
fan of pixar he's the sporty one of the
band and in real life josh has been in
shows like royal crush and friday night
lights but this was his first time
lending his voice to an animated
character to say he was surprised is a
bit of an understatement
number 13
bully on screen sweetheart in real life
the tyler actor knew exactly what his
job was in the movie i play tyler and
he's kind of like a bully to the main
character and her friends this early
career actor has already built up a
seriously impressive list of credits
including small roles in one division
the kaminsky method ron's gone wrong and
diary of a wimpy kid it's been a roller
coaster of a ride but chen has been
loving every minute of it teamwork makes
the dream work and they were always
super like oh do you need to go get a
drink of water they were really care
caring about it it was fun
number 14 we can't forget family mei's
dad jin was played by none other than
orion lee who has been acting for just
about 10 years but has a resume that
looks like he's been working for way
longer he also experienced what might
have been the most normal recording
sessions of all of his co-stars since in
australia where he was at the time of
filming there were hardly any
restrictions in place you know you can
pick a sound studio then everything can
be like professionally done and of
course wai ching ho as mei's grandmother
an actress with a resume that boasts
over 60 credits
number 15 a young but old pro
addison chandler has actually been doing
voice over work for a number of years so
hopping into the booth was no big deal
but just how big a film turning red was
made for a pretty special experience
super exciting and awesome and it
definitely a big ego boost i guess
devin might have been a smaller role but
chandler definitely made it a memorable
one
this cast is full of talents from many
walks of life and even though they
didn't get to work much in person
together they managed to infuse this
movie with all the heart and care
possible did any of the people behind
these voices surprise you